Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec quelqu'un de très particulier, ici chez moi, à ma maison.
C'est Tomy Millet.
C'est un pote d'enfance, un pote de primaire. C'est ça ?
-Non.
[rires] -Non, on vient de se croiser dans la rue, qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?!
C'était un "nouveau". Tu sais les nouveaux de l'école primaire. C'était un nouveau Tomy Millet parce qu'il nous a rejoint au CM1. C'est ça, CM1 ou CM2 ?
-Ouais, ouais.
-Et il y a quelques jours, il m'a envoyé un petit Tweet en me disant: "Hey je suis à Paris, on se voit ?"
Mais grave !
Je ne vais pas mentaliser Tomy, je vais te faire un tour de magie. Ça fait très longtemps que je n'ai pas fait de tours de magie sur la chaîne.
Avec un jeu de cartes, est-ce qu'elles sont bien toutes rouge ?
-Ça m'a l'air.
-Est-ce que tu veux mélanger ce jeu Tomy ? Est-ce que tu me fais confiance ou pas ?
-Si tu veux. Je suis sur scène, je ne peux pas te faire confiance de toute façon.
-Le mec il mélange, il a aucune confiance !
[rires]
Aucune !
C'est-à-dire que ça va faire plus de 20 ans en fait qu'on s'est rencontré, et il n'a pas la confiance.
-Ouais... Mais... Vu que je suis arrivé en tant que "petit nouveau" quand même, à l'école...
-C'est vrai.
-J'ai subi des brimades, parce que j'étais mal vu, forcément.
-Tu prends une carte, celle qui te fait le plus envie, le plus plaisir, peu importe.
-Moi je préfèrerai celle qui te dérangerai, moi. Par exemple celle là, je sais pas...
-Tu me dis quand tu en as une dans les mains.
-Je l'ai.
-Tu la fait voir à tout le monde à la caméra, mais sauf à moi, il ne faut pas que je puisse la voir.
C'est bon ou pas ?
Ouais ?
-Oui.
-Oui ? Il faut qu'on communique ensemble. Je te laisse la reposer.
C'est bon tu l'as reposée ?
-Là je la pose juste sur ton doigt. Ah non, il faut que je la mette dans le tas ?
-Non, non. On s'en fou. Regarde, on va même mélanger par au dessus si tu veux. Comme ça.
On peut même la perdre. On peut même mélanger en profondeur si tu veux. On peut même mélanger sans regarder si tu veux.
On peut même mélanger comme ça si tu veux.
Vengeance.
[rires]
Bon, là le problème, c'est qu'elle est vraiment perdue. Je me suis un peu enflammé sur les mélanges mais ce n'est pas grave.
J'ai cette capacité à retrouver les cartes.
Tu vois, c'est tout l'intérêt d'un tour d'ailleurs.
Si je pose le jeu là on le voit ?
Oui ! C'est formidable !
Alors, par contre il faut m'aider.
Tu te rends bien compte qu'il n'y a pas de miracle non plus. Il faut m'aider à retrouver la carte.
Pour ça, je vais les placer 5 par 5. Et toutes les 5 cartes je te demanderai si elle est passée.
Et toutes les 5 cartes tu me diras "non", "non", "non", jusqu'au moment où tu me diras "oui", évidemment.
Ca va c'est clair ou pas ?
-D'accord. Oui.
-Alors là par exemple, j'ai le 7♥, le 5♦, j'ai le 1♣, j'ai le 2♣, j'ai le 1♠.
Est-ce qu'elle est passée ?
Elle est passée ?
C'est vrai ou pas ?
Je le saurai après.
-Tu le sauras, ouais.
-Non, mais elle est passée ou pas ?!
-Ouais.
-J'ai du mal à te croire. C'est rare que ce soit dans les cinq premières en fait.
-Le pire c'est que je suis en train de me dire, attends, c'est laquelle, c'est laquelle, c'est laquelle, c'est laquelle...
parce que je me suis occupé de la montrer mais... je me suis dit c'est bon ils la voient !
[rires]
-Bon, attends. J'ai un test pour vérifier. Alors on va faire le test, c'est pas grave.
Tu tiens les 5 cartes comme ça, fermement. Et je vais en enlever une et une seule du bout des doigts.
Si c'est la tienne, c'est celle-ci que je sortirai.
Est-ce que c'est celle-ci ?
[rires]
Vous ne voyez pas la carte parce que c'est une carte invisible. Parce que figurez vous que quand je fais un tour de magie, je donne les moyens de faire un gros tour.
C'est ta carte ?
-D'accord. Oui, on va dire que oui alors !
-C'est quoi, c'est du trèfle c'est ça ?
[rires]
Si on dirait du trèfle.
Vous voyez du trèfle ou pas ?
Attends. Deuxième test. Parce que les cartes invisibles ont une tendance comme ça, elles flottent légèrement en l'air, elles ont du mal à retomber.
Tu vois.
Elle reste juste comme ça.
Et à ce moment précis, à ce moment précis en général, les gens ce disent que je raconte n'importe quoi.
Alors j'ai la preuve quand même de te prouver qu'il y a une carte invisible qui flotte.
-Moi j'ai l'impression qu'il raconte n'importe quoi depuis le début de la vidéo, mais bon...
-Mais non, mais pas du tout !
Regarde: 5 cartes moins 1 carte. Il est censé t'en rester combien ?
- Et bien 4.
-Ce mec a des capacités en calcul !
Compte les cartes.
Une, deux, trois, quatre.
Est-ce qu'il y a encore ta carte dedans ?
Est-ce qu'elle est à l'intérieur ?
Vas-y regarde les.
-Non, mais c'est bon, je les ai regardé.
-Elle n'y est pas ?
Non, parce qu'elle est là, en train de flotter ici, en l'air ! Tu vois. Par contre je peux la faire réapparaitre si tu veux.
-Ah tu me dégoutes.
-Regarde. Je te donne une bonne pichenette, Et ça lui permet de tomber.
Alors des fois, oui, des fois elle se retourne un petit peu.
Et d'atterrir dans le jeu.
Pas SUR le jeu, DANS le jeu !
Regarde. On voit bien à la caméra, oui.
-Donc là, genre je retourne la première, ce n'est pas elle ?
-Non.
Non, ça c'est le 10♠.
Par contre, si tu étales le jeu complètement, vas-y, étale le.
Etale le bien.
Parce qu'en plus tu t'es amusé à la mettre à l'envers ?
-Je pense qu'elle est tombé à l'envers !
-Je prends ça depuis tout à l'heure moi ! (la carte)
-Je pense qu'elle est tombé à l'envers, et en plein milieu du jeu. Et vu ta tête je pense que c'était l'As de ♣ !
Merci Tomy Millet !
Alors Tomy Millet il n'a pas d'actu parce que son actu, c'est sa vie personnelle évidemment !
-Ma vie elle est privée !
-Et sa vie elle est privée.
Mais je vous raconterai dans les commentaires !
Le mec il a des dossiers sur moi de ouf !
-Oui mais justement tu en as aussi, donc... tu te calmes !
-C'est vrai ! [rires]
-Tu te calmes Martine !
-On a des dossiers dans les deux sens !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette vidéo. Pensez à laisser un petit pouce en l'air si ce tour là...
-Abonnez-vous, abonnez-vous, abonnez-vous !!!
-Ecoutez, moi je ne voulais pas vous le dire. Mais apparemment...!
-Si tu cliques là, c'est pas compliqué et ça coûte rien !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !